[Musique]
bonjour
françois moi si vous voulez jouer et on
reprend donc le seul toit louis depuis
différents
on est parti sur un rosé plus sobre
said ait choisi son moment
wells après ça nous mène au maillet
thomas nomades ces jeunes filles
on a ici comme là-bas surtout ici
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe aïe mon coeur va chez là
pour toi la recherche
[Musique]
tu veux toi
à l'essai
[Musique]
et
merci à peu le passé c'est carrément
[Musique]
et
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu peux le faire mais lui contre moi
cette belle aventure une bête
face à affronter là
hélas non
aïe
il
frej et du samu
ce projet c'est un projet
cinématographique
[Musique]